Jared it's Ross Tucker here on the Dan
Patrick show great to talk with you
let's talk about the Warriors I mean
they're going to break the record now at
this point I would have to think and i
guess my first question here is just how
important is this record in your mind
how big a deal is a regular season
record but the things I'm groskreutz
talk to you but you're tuning into the
game yesterday seemed like a lot of
people were a definite locked in um yeah
I think it's important but um it's only
important to go ahead and win a title
you don't want to be known as the
greatest regular season in NBA history
and not win a championship so to follow
it up and you know also when you take
into context all that steph curry is it
has done this year and then the
opportunity to win an MVP again to go
maybe with a Finals MVP and then he's
got a chance to go with a gold medal
this summer to in the Olympics it's
gonna go down as one of the greatest
basketball years ever and you know the
fact that he may have a best regular
season is just remarkable so my second
favorite sport jared is basketball i
played through high school probably
could have played you know like d three
hoops if i wanted to but obviously my
body type let's say was better suited to
to football than trying to play college
basketball I never seen anything like
them and maybe I'm only 37 is there
anybody else that anybody even talks
about that compares to this guy despite
even just watching last night some of
the shots he made the layups even when
he attacked I think it was the I came
ever danny green or Kawhi Leonard at the
rim I mean it is ridiculous he is so
much more than just a shooter no I'm
glad you didn't ask for my body Piper
suited for that's why I let the games
about get to play them uh yet no curry
is he's not he's not rare to the average
human and I think that's what makes them
so likeable is that so many people say
that guy kind of looks like me or you
know he's not that much taller that that
much bigger than me
I think that you know we we kind of
relate to him in the fact that uh III
would hope people would recognize how
talented how skilled he is and how much
hard work he put into to UM didn't
special things he does in the court Ross
but you know you start to hear about the
mark prices of the world or guys who
just weren't that big because LeBron
like you not many people think that they
could be LeBron because you're not you
know 68 and 280 pounds you know so so
you can't relate to them um but the one
thing that I kind of caution people
about this year with steph curry and I
think Ross you know you saw a great
example of it yesterday is that yes
Steph Curry is in the conversation for
one of the greatest shooters of all time
but I think part of that takes away from
us recognizing how great of a basketball
player is really go down as well the
great ever I don't know he's got to
continue this for quite a while for us
to get him in that conversation of the
Michael Jordan's but what he does as a
ball handler as a distributor as a
driver you saw yesterday when the Spurs
drove him off the three-point line how
we was able to get the painting score
there in the creativity and he's got
this rep is being a guy who's on a great
defender and that's just not the case
anymore I mean not that he's going to be
an old world offender but I think a lot
of is there's so many other good
defenders on the steam that he doesn't
get asked to take on that responsibility
to all the time he's a very capable
defender now and he's just he sees the
complete package I won't people lose
sight of that yeah we're talking with
Jared Greenberg of NBA TV he's the host
over there you can see Jared on 10
before tip tonight at six pm eastern
time on NBA TV here's how I look at it
Jared you know LeBron is a physical
freak of nature Michael Jordan on some
level is a physical for me Michael drunk
had done from the foul line dude you
know he had crazy duck so he was a
physical freak of nature those guys are
both physical freaks of nature that
became very skilled and and obviously
two of the all-time greats and even Kobe
on some level to me curry is a skilled
freak of nature like his his
freakishness is his skills which
makes it so cool because the everyman
can at least think in their mind if I
put it enough time I could have skills
like Steph Curry yeah I gruvia arm but
you know you have to understand how hard
he does work and the stuff you know I
was in Memphis with the team on Saturday
night and uh I'm gonna pick him up again
when they return home for for
Wednesday's game again against Memphis
but what's happening now I've seen this
a few times covering warrior games on
the road this year is the crowds of
people to come out it really is turning
into what I remember growing up you know
in in the early mid 90s go to a baseball
game you know it's Mark McGwire barry
bonds or sammy sosa or one of these
great home run hitters was taking
batting practice and just to show before
the show and that's now curry where
people are coming out to see the work he
put in but it's not just for
entertainment but the stuff curry does
in pregame and the stuff that he's done
to get himself ready in his body to this
this level of its people talk about what
great shape he's in and and just the
endurance he has uh coaching staff raves
about that with curry he has worked so
incredibly hard on that it's paying off
now it's not just surface level like
this guy puts in so much time and just
as has done so much to get himself to
this point where he's the best player in
the game right now this year Jared where
do you stand on sort of the old-school
versus new-school debate not I've lost
track of all the you know old heads
saying that they would beat this Golden
State Warriors for nothing and look I I
told you I'm 37 right so I grew up with
you know the Pistons and the Bulls I get
it was a more physical game back then
but watching that game last night first
of all st. Antonio's good too but
watching those two teams go against each
other I'm not buying it I'm not buying
so every other sport people get bigger
faster stronger and they're in general
better now than they were 20 years ago
but basketball you're you're trying to
tell me that basketballs the one where
the teams for 20 years ago or better I'm
not buying it here are you yeah I'm
right there with you
you know I'm kind of the whole get off
my lawn thing it needs to stop we have
this you know need to make these
comparisons that we can't have an answer
to uh it's no I I get why we do it to a
certain extent but I don't necessarily
love it and I think that it's really
unfair just to make it so one-sided
because you know now the guys would have
to it's always a while well Steph Curry
wouldn't be able to play back in the 70s
or 80s well guess what now how do you
think the guys in the 78 or 80s would be
able to relate to the style of play
today and not that it's easier and
listen when they were scoring 120 points
a game back then where was where was a
great defense that everybody wants to
talk about that was being played that's
not being played now I just think that
it's just a it's unfair to there's no
right way to do it and I think it takes
it takes away from the greatness that's
happening in front of us right now and
here's your the other part of it too
that I want to add with a three-point
shot you know the evolution and the boom
that we're seeing so many people kureha
on a level that exceeds everything else
that's happening in Korea's eight
3-pointers away from 400 like nobody
sniffed 300 and curry going for four
hundred and so yes there's this
evolution where the game is moving
outside and guys are taking more of
those shops but curry has drunk even his
own generation in terms of his ability
to shoot so to knock him down a pedestal
i think it's just not fair as i write it
is not appreciating great incident in 10
years from now we're going like Matt you
remember one of the greatest regular
seasons in NBA history and it was step
her in the Warriors so Jerry the next
couple days are about team's jockeying
for playoff position and certain teams
trying to either make it or or they're
going home tell me why I should care
just in the sense that i feel like the
NBA is the sport where the least amount
of teams have a legitimate chance to win
it like what i mean how many teams could
honestly win the NBA title i mean four
or five so who gets in as the seventh or
eighth seed like this isn't hockey or
even baseball or even the NFL like does
it really matter whether or not you get
the seventh or eighth
or whether you make the playoffs because
you tell me how many teams have
legitimate chance to win this thing I
would say that full I mean honestly I
think it's the water spurs on one level
and then I would put a notch below but
if you want to put them in the
conversation I would say the Cavaliers
in the Thunder art there because they
have the talent they have the pieces to
do it on they haven't shown consistently
throughout the course of season uh but
there's certainly a big space between
the Warriors and Spurs and the Thunder
and caps I put those I put those four
teams in there to have a shot um now
listen whether it matters to make the
playoffs this year as the seventh or
eighth seed for these teams as the
average MBA then probably it doesn't
matter all that much because you're
right if they don't have much of a shot
you know it's not like baseball we count
on pitcher or hockey or account of a hot
goaltender but in terms of how it helps
a team grow and a franchise take a major
step in the right direction it does
factor in I mean you look at a team like
the Boston Celtics who got in as a seven
seas last year and we're fighting for
the three seed in the Eastern Conference
playoffs now and what it means for them
and you're right I wouldn't think Boston
has as much for shabbos there's a
massive unforeseen injury to somebody on
Cleveland's team but I still think it
means a lot to the growth of the sport
in the growth of the game or each one of
these teams as well to make sure they're
taking a step in the right direction
because very rarely do we see a team
just come out of nowhere and win a title
like the Warriors are a team that have
been growing for five years and yet they
wanted last year and they're the
favorite to repeat again but it started
a couple years ago with them getting to
the second round and nobody really saw
that coming on and then you know the
next year getting to the first round of
losing and then kind of building to
where they are today and obviously Mark
Jackson then over to Steve Kerr so in
the NBA it's all about us he'd use this
word because so many GM's use it and
makes you want to throw up sometimes
with the process of becoming a champion
and and it's we've seen the fruits of
the labor of the Golden State Warriors
and now you know they're putting
together with tiny ously right before
our eyes yeah I think that's a very fair
point Jared appreciate the time
appreciate and thanks for you guys give
it a shot out there to Hofstra I love
that
I know your guys in the studio or doing
that on purpose i love all right the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience